[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
في خطوه غير مسبوقه في تاريخه النظام
الايراني يعطل شرطه الاخلاق ويبحث الزاميه
الحجاب تنازل الحقيقي للاصلاح ام خطوه
شكليه لتهدئه وما تدعيه ذلك على الشارع
وعلى النظام وفي ملف نقشنا الثاني
الاقتصاد العالمي ولماذا انتقدته اوكرانيا
واختلف حوله الاوروبيون وهلتزمونه مع
الشمعاتك بس يحمل اي مغزى
وانا نحييكم الى التفاصيل على وقع
احتياجات لم تهدئتها منذ مقتل الشاب مساء
اميني في سبتمبر الماضي اعلنت ايران حلها
شرطه الاخلاق وهي خطوه نصرت الجدل حيث
اعتبرها البعض بدايه لسلسله من التنازلات
في حال استمرار الاحتجاجات واخرون نظروا
اليه على انها خطوه شكليه تكتيكيه لتهدئه
الشارع اما فيما يتعلق بالحجاره فقط اكد
المداعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر منتظري
ان البرلمان والقضاء يعملان على مراجعه
القانون الذي يفرض على النساء
للمتظاهرين وقد يتسبب في اشتعال المزيد من
الاحتجاجات على املي تحقيق كامل لاهداف
الشعب الايراني
اعزائي دستورنا له مواد ثابته وغير قابله
للتغيير جمهوريه النظام واسلاميته ومبدا
الاستقلال والحريه والحقوق والحريات التي
يصرح بها الدستور اساليب واليات لتطبيق
القانون ولكن يمكن دراستها
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
الدكتوره احمد قنديل خبير وشؤون الاسيويه
في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه اهلا
بك و بعد قليل كذلك سينضم لنا من بيروت
سيد مصطفى فحص الكاتب الصحفي احييكم ضيوفي
سابدا معك دكتور قنديل دكتور قنديل في
الواقعه اجراءات مهمه وصفها البعض يتخذها
النظام الايراني ابرز هذه الاجراءات قبل
مناقشه موضوع الحجاب ولكن اتخذ قرار يخص
شرطه الاخلاق واعلن همم الغاء او تعطيل
على الاقل هذه الشرطه هل تعتقد حظرتك بان
يمكن القول بان المحتجين كسبوا المعركه
وبان النظام قادر على ان يصلح نفسه ام كما
يقول منتقده النظام الايراني هي جرعه
مورفين لتهدئه ليس اكثر
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى حضرات الساده
المشاهدين اعتقد ان هي ااا ان المتظاهرون
حققوا انجازا كبيرا وحقيقيا في مواجهه
نظام اييي يعني يستخدم كل اساليب القمع
اييه ويحاول اطفاء نار الغضب التي اشعلها
في صدور الايرانيين على مدار 40 اكثر من
اربعه عقود اا من ال- ال- ال- ال- ال- حكم
الملالي ونشر الفوضى في المنطقه على حساب
الشعب الايراني اعتقد ان هي منوره تكتيكيه
همم يهدف بها النظام ارسال عده رسائل الى
الداخل والخارج همم النظام يبدو انه يعد
او يحاول اعداد الجبهه الداخليه ل همم
مواجهه طويله الامد مع الخارج في ظل تعثر
الاتفاق النووي وفي ظل القرار الاخير الذي
اتخذته
تران بشان ايه استئناف تخصيب اليورانيوم
في تحدي واستفزاز كبير للمجتمع الدولي
وبالتالي يبدو ان النظام الحاكم حاليا
يحاول يعني تسكين او اعطاء حقنه مورفين زي
ما حضرتك وصفت للشعب في محاوله لتقديره من
اجل همم
هذه المواجهه الخارجيه طبعا همم من
المتوقع ان يحدث هذا التنازل من جانب
النظام الايراني هزه كبيره في دعائم هذا
النظام اللي بيقوم على اسس ايدولوجيه وكان
همم مساله شرطه الاخلاق احد دعائم وركائز
هذه همم الشرعيه الايدلوجيه همم للنظام
سيد مصطفى هل تتفق مع ضيفه بانها جرعه
مهدئه و بانه خاصه تنازل من النظام هل
تنازل النظام من خلال الغائه لشرطه
الاخلاق تعتقد
اهلا مساء الخير لا ادري هل صدرك قرار
رسمي بالغاء شرطه الاخلاق ام ان حديث نقل
عمود دعيه ام طهران ايضا نحتاج الى ان
ننتظر القرار الرسمي رغم ان حل شرطه
الاخلاق او
وقف عملها لا يحتاج الى القضاء لانها هي
فرع في الشرطه الايرانيه
استحدثا ما بين 2005 و2000 و2006 هو ليس
تنازل هو محاوله معينه خطوه الى الوراء
يا واهي يا جزئيه مهمه همم من الجهه
المخوله الغاء او تعطيل نهائي لشرطه
الاخلاق لان المدعي العام الايراني لما
سئل عن هذا الموضوع قال من اسسها الغاه
يعني وزاره الداخليه
الوزاره وزاره وزاره الداخليه نعم ولكن
هناك ما هو اخطر ما هو اصعب من شرطه
الاخلاق هناك هيئه الامر بالمعروف والنهي
عن المنكر كاشتار الله الذين من ازرع
البسيج الذين يمارسون القمع العام في
ايران ضد المواطنين
في نوعيه الارتداء في طبيعه الحركه يعني
يتابعون حتى الحياه اليوميه للناس وهم
الاداه القمعيه الاساسيه والاخطر على
المجتمع الايراني كما ان المجتمع بعد
ثلاثه اشهر قد تجاوز قضيه الحجاب فهناك
محاوله ان يرجع عود خطوه الى الوراء من
اجل استيعاب الصدمه ولكن هل النظام
الايراني في يستطيع التنازل الطبيعه
الواحده للنظام بمعنى حزب الله هي النظام
بعد انتخاب رئيسي وانتهاء المعتدلين
والاصلاحين في هذه الطبيعه كلام الرئيس
الايراني عن الدستور اليوم او الامس وايضا
كلام ياخذ كلام الرئيس فيه جزء من الطبيعه
الفرد الايراني وحتى اللغه الايرانيه
وجدنا المبتدا ولم نعصر في الجمله على خبر
هناك تفسير ظاهره هناك تفسير باطل
العمليه الحجاب او وقف القمع من اجل
الارتداء غطاء الرازي عمليه في الاليات
الدستوريه بعيده عن الشرطه وبعيده عن
قرارات شرطه الاخلاق هذا في كلام رئيسي له
علاقه في جوهر الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في شكل
المبادئ ومتراه من حريات هل هذا ممكنا هل
هل النظام سيصل مع نفسه الى حل وسط لانه
لا يمكن ان يصل الى هل وسط مع مع الشارع
لانه
لا يستطيع التنازل ام انه يخترع او يعيد
انتاج تيار اصلاح ما تيار معتدل ما من اجل
ان يتنازل تنازل داخلي يعني نوع من تحول
اوراق داخل مش انقلاب قصر بقدر ما هو
تحريك الشطرنج الداخلي داخل تركيب التحضير
الدكتور قنديل دكتور قنديل هل تعتقد بانه
هذه الخطوه هي كما قال السيد مصطفى عمليه
تحريك لبيادق شطرنج داخلي همم او ان هناك
همم امكانيه ان يعدل النظام نفسه ضيف
يستبعد ذلك يقول بان النظام لن يعدل لن
يصلح نفسه وهي حركه من بين الحركات التي
يتعمد القيام بها لتهدئه حضرتك هل ترى
بانه مسك العصا من الوسط قادر ان يقوم به
نظام الايراني
نعم انا اتفق في كثير من ما قالوا ضعيفك
الكريم واعتقد ان هذه مخاطره كبيره يتبعها
النظام الايراني الحالي لان اي تنازل حتى
لو كان محدودا في صوره الغاء شرطه الاخلاق
ربما يشجع على مزيد من الاحتجاجات
والتظاهرات
ومزيد من المطالب التي تنال ال- ال- ال-
المجال السياسي
وحتى الدستور في
قمه هذا المجال السياسي لا شك ان هذه
علامه ضعف همم من جانب النظام الايراني
وادراكا منه الاخطاء التي ارتكبتها شرطه
الاخلاق ومن كان يقف وراء شرطه الاخلاق في
الاونه الاخيره وبالتالي اعتقد ان همم
نظريه الدومنه قد
يعني في ايران مزيد من الاحتجاجات مزيد من
التنازلات حتى انهار الاسس التي قام هذا
النظام واحدا تلو الاخر وبالتالي مساله
استخدام بياضك او شطرنج ربما يعني تكون
لها اا يعني اا اثر
تدميري للنظام الحاكم
سيد مصطفى لماذا لما سالت منذ قليل عن هذا
الاجراء
اجبت بسؤال كذلك وقلت بانه هل تم حقيقه
الغاء شرطه الاخلاق وكانك تستبعد وكانك
تطرح استفهامات عن همم
نيه همم النظام الحقيقيه في الغاء هذه
الشرطه هل يمكن ان تكون هذه التصريحات
تصريحات مجرد بروباندا همم لتهدئه الشارع
ولكن ستعود شرطه الاخلاق بشكل اخر هذا ما
وردت قوله ربما
نعم اول تحدي كبير امام النظام هل صدر
قرار هذا النظام خطوه الى الوراء كما كان
كان عم يقول الدكتور عزيز الدكتور قنديل
اا خطوه الى الوراء هي خطبه تاخذ الى
خطوات حجر حجاره الدومينو صدور قرار رسمي
صعب اذا اصدره كيف سينفذه كيف سيمرره
داخليا داخل اروقه النظام وكيف سيتقبل
الشعب الان هو يرمي قنابل دخانيه او حمام
كما قام بتعديل مثلا على شرطه الاخلاق في
2015 تعلم حظرتك انا شرطه الاخلاق كان
مخول لها اقتياد الناس الذين لا ينتسلون
للقواعد اقتيادهم لمكان
اعتقال وحتى همم همم للقضاء ولكن كانت
هناك انتقادات وعدل من نفسه وهمم صارت
شرطه الاخلاق فقط تقودهم لاماكن يقول
النظام بانهم همم يقدم لهم في هذه الاماكن
بعض النصائح فلماذا تستبعد تماما ان يكون
هناك التغيير همم على هذا المستوى
النظام الايراني انه استبداد ديني يعني
يتفاقم عمليات الاستبداد استبداد كما ان
بالاستبداد الديني يعني عمليه لاهوت
التحرير او الاصلاح الديني من الصعب ان
يتقبل طبيعه نظام عقائدي بالمستوى ان
النظام الايراني فهو لا يستطيع ان يتنازل
للشعب والاصلاح وعمليه من يحفر قبره بيده
بالنسبه لنظام ولا يستطيع ان ان
يعترف ان الشعب انتزع منه همم شيء من
مطالبه لذلك بطبيعه النظام لا يستطيع ان
يذهب الى نوع من الاصلاح الديني لانه هو
كان نظام عقائدي وهو استبداديني فلذلك هذه
المخاطره وتتقاطع مصالح النظام الهرميه في
هذا في هذا الش في هذا الشان كما ان ال هو
يحتاج الى كثير من الاليات للسيطره على
مؤسسات الدوله وعلى المجتمع وعلى
ولذلك يجب ان يحمي ادواته فمستوى اليد
يتخلى به عن شرطه الاخلاق سيكون محدود اما
ان هناك مغامره ان يتخلى عن شرطه الاخلاق
ان يطاع يعتبرها شرطه توجيهيه لا تتدخل في
المباشر ولكنه سيطلق العنايه للامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر لقوات البسيج
لكش تسال الله لكل هذه القضايا التي تقمع
الناس ليس فقط تحت غطاء تحت الحجاب تحت
تحت رائع عقائديه كبيره بانها هؤلاء الناس
جميعهم ليس فقط الحجاب اصبحوا معاذين
لنظام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه فيحكمون بالرده
وعده فتاوى قد تصدر عنها احكام اعدام
فلذلك صعب على النظام هو في موقع خارج وفي
ماسك يتنازل كيف ما هو المستوى التنازل
وامامنا شارع نحن نتحدث عن النظام هل
الشارع سينضي في هذا الاصلاح هل سيعتبره
اخذ مكاسبه وسيط اعتقد ان ما يحدث في
ايران نحن ابواب لشهر الثالث قد تجاوز
النظام والشرطه الاخلاق وعقائد النظام
وتركيبه النظام والاهم من كل شيء تجاوز
الاصلاحين اي المعارضه في الداخل
والمعارضه في الخارج ففي ايران
تفسيره تتفق مع ذلك الدكتور قنديل وان كنت
تتفق ملتي يبدو بان الصوره القادمه اقدم
من من مشاهداه في ما قبل البعض يقول بان
هذه الاحتجاجات قادره ان تتوسع اكثر وان
اا هذا الاجراء الاخير من النظام الايراني
لن يهدئ بل بالعكس هو قادر ان يفسح المجال
المزيد من المطالب من المطالب المطالبات
نعم اعتقد ذلك الى حد كبير ان هذا التنازل
سوف
يعقبه مزيد من الاحتجاجات للمطالبه بقى
بامور اخرى الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في ايران
بالغه السوء والنظام الايراني الايراني
يدرك تماما ان شعبيته تترنح وانه يعني
الاوراق التي ما تزال في يده ربما تم
استنزانه يعني اصبحت قليلا للغايه اداه
القمع للمتظاهرين اداه القتل والاعتقال
يبدو انها لم تؤدي همم
بنجاح كان يتوقعه المسؤولون في طهران همم
على الاقل هل توافق من يقول بانه
اخذنا جديد حضر تقول بان همم
السجن همم التعذيب لم تاتي اكلها او على
الاقل لم تاتي بالنتائج التي انت النظام
فاتخذ قرارات جديده هذه القرارات او هذا
التعديل حتى في مواجهه هذه الاحتجاجات
يراها البعض بانها شيء جديد
الحكم عن مدى نجاعه هذه القرارات في تهدئه
غضب الشارع الايراني القرار ما يزال اتخذا
صباح اليوم ردود الفعل لم تتقطع لنا بعد
ولم اا يعني اا يتم باختبار هذا تنازل غير
مسبوق من جانب النظام الايراني همم قد
يكون هناك همم نجاح في همم مساله تهدئه
التوترات لكن هذه النجاحات او هذه تهدئه
لن تستمر طويلا تحت الظروف الاقتصاديه
الصعبه تحت وط- استمرار العقوبات الغربيه
ورفض الجوار الايراني لايك مصالحات مع هذا
النظام في ظل زعزعته للامن والاستقرار في
دول الجوار في ظل دعوه
المسلحه في العديد من الدول العربيه
وبالتالي همم يعني همم المساله سوف
تستمر لفتره طويله قادمه همم على الارض
يعني اما سيد مصطفى هل تعتقد بان النظام
قادر على طرح فكره تعديل الدستور ولو ان
الموضوع مستبعد ولو ان ايران لم تشهد
تعديل الا سنه 89 اعتقد بعد دستور يقول
البعض بانه صيغه على عجل مباشره بعد
الثوره ولكن اتت دستور المعدل نسبيا سنه
89 فكان همم اشد همم كرامه مما سبق هل
تعتقد بان النظام قادر ان يطرح من جديد
فكره تعديل الدستور او كما يقول البعض
تعديل الدستور يعني تغيير النظام يعني همم
نهايه المرشد
هلا هو لما نعد للنظام يمكن عده الفقرات
101 او 111 ناسيها اللي هي تعني حجم سلطه
الدستوريه انا لا اعطل لا يجب ان نتعامل
مع النظام الايراني كان نظام جامد او
حديدي بالشكل الذي نراه لماذا لان ايضا ما
لا نراه نحن حتى الان وهذا اعتقاد او
تحليل ان هناك صراع مراكز قوى ايضا في
ايران هذا صراع مراكز القوى يستفيد ايضا
من حركه الاحتجاجات ويستفيد ايضا من الطرف
الذي تصدى ويعتبر الى الان قد هزم امام
حركه الاحتجاجات وهو يلمح الى التنازل
امامها
داخل اليات النظام مجموعه مراكز قوى
النظام هناك من
يجلس في كمين كمين داخل وليس كبير
للمتضررين هذا الكلام
الذي وضعتها اجنحه على بعضها تطرح فكره
المرحله الانتقاليه مستقبل ايران ما بعد
السيد خامنئي مستقبل المرشد المقبل حجمه
ودوره لان ها كل هذا يحدث على انعكاساته
على طبيعه النظام فاذا فكره تعديل الدستور
في ايران قائمه ولكن في الاولويه هي اول
هي في يد صراع مراكز القوه داخل النظام في
تقاسم السلطه او في اخراج شكل السلطه
مستقبلا وليس في حساباتهم ما يطلبه الشارع
الايراني لذلك علينا ان نفر ان نفرق ما
بين التعديلات التي قد تطرا بسبب
الاحتجاجات ولكن نتيجه لصراعات مراكز
القوى في المرحله الانتقاليه التي يمر بها
النظام اما التعديلات التي يريدها الشارع
فهي لا تتقاطع ابدا مع اي شيء من من نصوص
الجوهريه في دستور الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
فا- همم قراءتك لما قاله الرئيس الايراني
بخصوص ان الدستور ليس جامد هكذا قال فقرا
الباب بان ربما المجال مفتوح لتعطيل هذا
وارد تعتقد
اعتقد ان مساله تعديل الدستور مساله غايه
في الصعوبه في ظل ال ال ال موازين القوه
الداخليه في ايران في الفتره الحاليه اي
هز لهذا الدستور واي تعديل له قد يؤدي الى
حدوث همم انقلاب من جانب ال- ال- القوه
المتشدده في النظام التي لها اتباعها
ومريدين في قوات الحرس الثوري همم
الايراني وهذا هو احد اعتقد الجوابح
الكوابح الاساسيه امام اي تعديل للدستور
وبالتالي سوف يكون الامر بالغ الحساسيه
لانه قد يؤدي الى سقوط النظام بشكل تام في
ظل تنافس القوه الحالي
القادمه
من القاهره دكتور احمد قنديل خبير شؤون
الاسيويه في مركز الاهرام لدراسات
السياسيه ومن بيروت والصفحص الكاتب الصحفي
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]